soon this is fun surviving an active
shooter l.a county sheriff this is great
uh
an active shooter is part of american
life
um i don't even know if it's a bad part
it's just something
i don't even think you have to look at
it negatively it's a great time for you
to show your ingenuity and your skill
set but this video surviving an active
shooter uh this is from 2015
because we've had this problem for a
minute
um
let's play a little bit of this okay now
where did this go out to who who got
this video so this is the la county
sheriff's made this but this has been
making the rounds on twitter as this
here which i haven't been able to find
because companies play it for people
when they get hired now at places
watching active shooter training for
work yeah [ __ ] is insane yeah and it's
it's just like this guy just like just
going ape [ __ ] on people in the in the
place and like everybody watches this
before you work at sears
part of an american
workplace yeah
so somebody taking a gun out of their
bag
in the middle of the day
and blowing people's heads off is part
of an american workplace if you don't
like it move to mexico city
like any other turned tragic today when
an employee opened fire on his
supervisor and fellow co-workers
students parents they turned the
comments off for this obviously after a
bloody rest yeah i would imagine
are just coming in but we're being told
that a heavily armed gunman opened fire
this evening at the mall food court
behind me there's no official word i'll
skip forward here here we go
this is for the people to know how to
survive in any situation you got to get
some sleep you're looking like a vampire
you sleep you ain't got no babies at
home keeping you up
what the hell
oh sam again we've tried i'm sorry
we're gonna have to let you go
[Music]
active shooter killings are a tragedy
what it is predictable reality and how
much blood and so much blood that's so
much by the way let's go back to that
that is so much blood
tragic so much blood
she goes listen we're gonna have to let
you go
we're gonna have to let you go and then
he just blows her head off
i was like [ __ ] but i want to work at
this warehouse
you're telling me i can't work at this
warehouse
it just goes out like it's just 2006 the
us has averaged an active shooter event
with four or more deaths every 2.9
months
even though the number of active shooter
events has been increasing
your odds of being involved in one are
still very slim that's nice but just
like fire drills and earthquake
preparedness making a plan in advance
can make all the difference
lizards live in tanks i love this like
l.a
like these like weird the dialogue that
they write in between
the active shooter the guy with the
babies one guy's like you ain't got
babies keeping you up and then this girl
walks in and she goes lizards live in
tanks
what is strange
it's odd
and all these people are in la like
wanting to be actors they're they're all
of course i mean you gotta get a gig
a senseless attack the why doesn't
matter hey
hey buddy
[Music]
what matters is surviving okay how on
average 20 stop telling us we know how
do i survive
how do i do it killers usually choose
their victims at random they offer easy
targets that's not comforting so the
harder you are to see or to hit the
safer you are smart
smart
when an attack starts if you can find a
way out of the location do so
get out
smart
if you stay calm and think clearly even
in the middle of a life and death event
you improve your chances of making it
out
visualize your movements in advance what
are we gonna do look at me look at me i
can get us out stay behind
use cover something that will stop a
bullet and concealment something that at
least keeps you out of sight use cover
something that would stop a bullet
use cover
something that would stop a bullet okay
245 esv 417
town center i love just like the 901
guys so routine he's like they're
shooting up the mall again
hey we have hello is anyone working out
there yeah we've got another shooting at
the mall food court um
you know
what else you want me to tell you it's
america
it's wearing a face mask possible body
armor use any available means to get out
including emergency exits or windows
most restaurants and retail locations
will also have exits in the back through
kitchens or stockrooms how great would
it be to see a guy just like following
them through that just shooting at them
you're not getting away
this part's crazy here with
a second
even in the best cases police are
minutes not seconds away
you must take action to protect yourself
[Music]
okay
everybody stay calm it's probably just a
drill
damn i mean it's like john wick
the production is insane
[Applause]
[Music]
if you can help others without putting
yourself i mean in other countries
playing this
i mean they just go what a barbaric like
society it's hilarious yeah
uh i want to get to the part with the
cops because they're like don't they uh
about how to approach the police so they
don't shoot you the one thing i like
about this video so far is they've not
pretended the cops are gonna help you
like that is what i like right like
there's actually been no like wait for
the cops or the cops are on their way
the only thing they've said is the cops
are minutes not seconds away and i think
they should also follow that up with
they may not even come in
the cops may choose to stand outside for
an hour so don't even think they'll
necessarily help you
yeah because you're supposed to assist
the injured like you're she's doing well
huh she just got shot she's like oh boy
if you can't move safely to her i wonder
why she didn't book any other roles or
confined areas can you go back to that
please yeah i wonder why she didn't book
any other roles she
got she just got shot watch this if you
can help others without putting yourself
in unnecessary danger
do something okay
what's your name
laurie
i'm mori
then secure the location
it is weird they tell you to do
everything you secure the location
well no i like that no this is at least
honest they're not telling you the cops
are coming to help you
oh my god there's somebody shooting
well that girl smiled the black girl
smiles over here
go back to that
no no
she goes in because there's so much
shooting the black girl literally smiles
watch this there's somebody shooting
look
she
smiles amazing she literally smiled
you'd think that they were you'd think
the director would be like no no you're
upset about this right right you're
upset this development bothers me
no but i mean go back one more time yeah
the girl literally
smiles
this girl comes because there's somebody
shooting this girl literally smiles oh
my god there's somebody shooting
everybody stay calm remember how i mean
she's smiling like flirtatious corner
from the window funny like emergency bag
he's like oh this could be a fun day
drywall won't stop a bullet
but there are steps to take to stay safe
okay we'll barricade the doors turn off
the lights move away from any windows
and silence your cell phone
smart lock
move desks or anything just block it
modern emergency bag can include a first
aid kit gloves emergency plans for the
building and casualty cards to alert
first responders to any wounded victims
the cops are still not here it's two
hours later situations are over in 10 to
15 minutes attention lakewood it's
called threes neither at 245 gsb 417
[Music]
law enforcement's first responsibility
when entering an active shooter
situation is to stop the suspect not to
render aid to the victims
medical teams will enter the scene as
soon as the suspect is no longer a
threat or is confirmed in another
location
silence any cell phones and remain quiet
do not alert the shooter to your
presence
uh oh
you see just like a snapchat
notification go off
[Laughter]
the morbidly obese cops are here look
how fat the cops are go back to that go
back to how fat the cops are they're
very fat finally after 15 minutes the
fattest cops you've ever seen will
arrive
here they come
there they are
the piglets are here
sheriff's department is there anyone
inside
yes
so this is this i don't even understand
just hang tight
what is that you're supposed to like
show law enforcement like a red card
it's called the casualty card yeah
you still don't have one you fill out a
casualty card about who made it and who
didn't and you put it outside the door
what's the problem
what's the problem